I'm honored to be here today to
recognize the man that we all knew and
love my dad Kobe Bryant when most people
knew him as a basketball player or
storyteller
I got to know and love him as my dad
and let me tell you
he is the MVP of girl dads to say the
least
being the dad of four girls is
definitely not easy but despite the NBA
and Laker schedules
he always made sure to support me and my
sisters being his daughter is one of the
greatest joys of my life
and I hope to continue to embody and
cherish the many lessons he has taught
me as you visit here for years to come
I encourage you to place your hands in
his and take a moment to stand in his
shoes we will love you forever and
always
love Natalya Gianna
Bianca Capri and Mommy